[Music]
I'm Mike and I created Surf's Up surf
set really started out of necessity I
couldn't get to the ocean I really loved
the way that the body type and the
fitness level that I attained while
surfing so I needed to create a workout
that can mimic that this is your at-home
surf set core workout hey guys so today
we're going to be running you through a
surf set core workouts we're going to
start first with walking planks alright
so what I do is walk my feet back come
down from here you're gonna be focusing
on flexing the core so much as possible
ones pulling that bellybutton to the
ceiling
all right now I'm gonna rock forward and
come up and come back down
stabilizing nice and controlled so you
got 15 seconds okay this next one just
called wave runners okay so what you're
gonna do is everybody forward and back
okay sort of like a mountain climber
from here we're gonna go right into
country level sit-ups okay so now we're
gonna be turning over okay onto our back
here and we're gonna go alternate hand
to alternate foot okay so from here
reaching up touching switching alright
then from there come back forward
alright so we're gonna start with what
Turkish gets okay so we're gonna use
that left hand
okay so left hand is always gonna be up
in the air okay
we're gonna push up
and push off with that right hand crank
them all the way up come back down nice
and controlled now you can add a weight
for this if you want pushing up and
again making sure we're staying in that
narrow area focusing on that core of the
whole time alright and the last one
similar to that waverunner we're gonna
set the core be in that push up plank
we're gonna bring that left knee forward
pull if you want to make this a little
bit more full-body play it back now
we're going to come down and then hold
okay and come back
alright so we're gonna do is we're going
to do each 15 seconds except for the
Turkish get ups could be doing those for
30 seconds okay okay alternating 15
seconds on the right 15 seconds on the
left with the hand that you're leading
with okay so make sure your back nice
and flat there okay try that core in
tight belly button to the ceiling
all right so tight all right now rocking
forward pull yourself and standing up
through the core there you go
perfect one nice job
alright now into the next movement here
alright we're gonna bring in waivers
okay so the goal is to bring those knees
through the middle of your two elbows
okay
it's about space between your two elbows
that's where you want to drive that knee
forward just make sure you don't hit
your chin all right all right you guys
so 15 seconds when you ready fire away
it's a nice flat nice and controlled
staying in that same spot alright
there's next set we're going right into
the contralateral situps all right all
right so right arm left foot all times
we're going alternate foot alternate arm
so as you come up full extension nice
touch
make sure we're focusing on flex
nightcore getting that full workout okay
hit it here we go yeah and use that
opposite hand that's not doing anything
for balance nice and focus there you go
we're gonna go into Turkish get-ups all
right so you're going to lead you're
gonna push up with that right hand
nice and explosive movement set the core
so again if you need weight you want to
make a little bit more resistance make
that work out a little bit harder a
little bit more efficient that's it go
one more over there standing all right
so now we're flipping over so this time
we're gonna add that push up alright
push up
we're gonna push up first drop down hold
at the bottom then bring that left knee
or right knee forward which other leg
you wanna start with there you go and
then back
compound movement that's what we're
about efficient workouts how would feel
like good that's right thank you
so to recap the surf set core workout we
start off with 15 seconds of walking
planks all my 15 seconds of runner
planks then we went to the contralateral
sit ups 15 seconds of those and then 15
per side of the Turkish get ups for
total 30 seconds finishing off with a
15-second knee to elbow point you beat
that twice that gives you your three
minutes surf set core workout thank you
sir awesome good morning thank you
[Music]